i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle from orlando for our american
comeback town hall with florida governor
ron desantis
now we have an amazing crowd
i mean
i mean this is a rad tag group but we're
gonna keep them here okay they're pretty
fun we've been hanging out with them now
last year almost to the day it's hard to
believe it's been a year we all gathered
here in the same location with five
republican governors who pledged to keep
their states open to grow their
economies and to protect the basic
freedoms of their residents we never had
a statewide mass mandate we never did a
stay-at-home order in the
far left of the democratic party who
believe that government should control
all decisions made by all americans and
that's something that we have to be
willing and able to stand up and push
back against we're going to give parents
100 percent option to have their child
in the classroom five days a week and
every school district in the state of
iowa is going to adhere to that it
doesn't matter what your color what your
background is texas is a land of
opportunity for absolutely everybody and
we want to unite everybody not divide
we're not having vaccine passports in
the state of florida
and
not just saying government can't make
you
private businesses can't make you
because here's the thing you have a
right to participate in society without
them asking you to divulge this type of
health information we will have a
resurgence of freedom in this country
and 2022 i think is going to be a great
year for us
in every single one of those governors
lived up to their pledges
but the democrats in the media they
really thought they hoped that these
anti-lockdown governors would be
finished politically
but now well we see they were right all
along now a recent report shows that the
states with the most draconian coveted
rules like new york they fared poorly
and states like florida were among the
best
and today
the new york times
grudgingly conceded that governor
desantis has governed with remarkable
effect embracing policies that once
seemed unthinkable
but he's been under relentless assault
by the press for an entire entire term
really as governor
and this is because though in the past
year alone he's taken on the left more
aggressively than any u.s governor in
modern memory meanwhile on the national
level
year over year
things are rapidly falling apart under
biden's leadership
negative economic growth soaring prices
millions streaming across the border
rising crime and obviously muddled
foreign policy
all self-inflicted damage by the
democrats in charge
so no wonder the american people who
overwhelmingly are thinking that things
are going to get worse in this country
not better
yet here florida
things are booming hundreds of thousands
of people are flocking here for peace
freedom
and opportunity
so tonight
we're going to examine
the man leading the sun sunshine state
which some are calling the laboratory
for in your face right-leaning policy
so can desantis's approach actually be
replicated elsewhere
and what's next
uh in his showdown with disney and will
hispanic voters and women
support this no holds barred take no
prisoners approach in november hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else